since Republicans have taken over
control of the House of Representatives
they have held a bunch of these
different hearings that are of course
hearings meant only to Virtue signal and
meant only to not focus on issues
actually facing the country this
includes hearings about big Tech or the
weaponization of the FBI and yesterday
there was one such Hearing in which they
brought out
the Attorney General Merritt Garland to
answer questions Ted Cruz went to law
school and yet he seemed completely
confused about how the law Works in this
first clip and these hearings really
went wrong so quickly and we'll talk
about what these are really meant to
accomplish in a moment in this first
clip
Ted Cruz starts talking about leaks and
Merit Garland has to explain to him
remember Cruz is a lawyer no no no that
wasn't a leak that was a court filing
those are by definition made public take
a listen to this as you know the FBI
rated
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago home
and subsequent to that raid there have
been multiple leaks about what was
discovered there including a photograph
of documents that were discovered there
did you know about the leaks
rate the photograph was a filing in
court in response to a motion filed by
Mr trump it was not a leak so so you're
testified there haven't been leaks about
the the Trump raid investment I'm
responding to the point yeah Ted Cruz is
a lawyer doesn't he know how the law
Works he went to law school well it
doesn't matter because Ted Cruz is there
not as someone with some legal knowledge
as as rudimentary as it might be he's
there as a performer who is there to
attack Merit Garland and to further a
narrative that everything that has gone
on with the investigation into Donald
Trump has been some kind of politically
biased subterfuge or plan or whatever
the case may be then the subject comes
up of protesters outside the homes of
Supreme Court Justices and again
I'm guessing Ted Cruz knows this stuff
but Ted Cruz wants to pretend that it is
up to Merit Garland to enforce statutes
but it is actually up to law enforcement
on the scene and it is another one of
these just deranged performative moments
that Ted Cruz thinks make him look
really good how do you decide which
criminal statutes the the doj enforces
and which one it doesn't the United
States Marshals know that they have full
I recognize you want to give a separate
speech how do you decide which statute
you enforce and which ones you don't but
Marshall's on scene make that
determination in light of the priority
of the marshals do not make a
determination over whether to prosecute
you the attorney general make a
determination and you spent 20 years as
a judge and you're perfectly content
with justices being afraid for their
children's lives
and you this this is understand this is
merely a performance this is not to
investigate or learn a damn thing did
nothing to prosecute it let's shift to
it can I answer the question
refuse to answer I am answering her I'm
you're not I'm here to perform uh uh Mr
attorney general not for you to answer
my questions questions
how did you choose not to not to enforce
this statute the marshals on scene don't
make that decision do make the decision
of whether to make an arrest someone no
they don't if they make them if they
make it Marshalls do not have
prosecution they make an arrest
because our time is limited the time is
limited because Ted Cruz won't actually
let the witness answer the questions and
of course Ted Cruz is blending two
different things Ted Cruz is blending
what actions were and weren't taken at
the homes of Supreme Court Justices
which is completely up to law
enforcement and then as a separate
matter wants Merit Garland to discuss
indictments which are a separate issue
to actions taken or not taken at the
homes of law enforcement and again I
know Ted Cruz is like sort of dim but
he's not this dim and we all know Ted
Cruz knows that Ted Cruz then continues
in turning he's determined to turn this
hearing into a farce which he very
easily did and he starts talking about
what is effectively a conspiracy theory
for which there is no evidence arguing
that the Department of Justice leaked
about investigating Hunter Biden to
serve as a pretext to indict Trump by
being able to say see we're nonpartisan
if that's confusing to you if that
doesn't make sense to you it's because
it doesn't make sense
toward that end the Department of
Justice has leaked that doj is
investigating and intends to indict
Hunter Biden
the purpose of those leaks I believe was
to set the predicate for an indictment
of trump to say I love how even-handed
we are we're indicting abiding we're
indicting a trump
those leaks are not law
speculation
conspiracy theory unfounded no evidence
and also not a question to the witness
that is there
but remember these hearings in sum total
are performances that's what they are
meant to be
that's what they are meant to be
um another interesting moment was in
this exchange with Ted Cruz Merrick
Garland points out you know some of you
Republican senators are arguing that we
leak to help the left
now you're saying the leaks are to help
the right it's all incoherent but good
for merit Garland for pointing it out
the answer is the leaks are consistently
on one side of the aisle advancing one
political agenda so
it doesn't seem to me attorney general
that the FBI has a lot of confidence in
you because what they're doing clearly
is trying to distance themselves from
your decisions they're out there leaking
left right and center and saying it
wasn't us we didn't want to do it he
made us do it right what's that say
about their confidence in your
leadership so understand here and and
Garland will address it Cruz is arguing
you're making all these leaks to help
the left and Josh Hawley is saying the
leaks are coming out actually from
people who don't agree with you in order
to help the right no the previous
Senator said that they're leaking all in
favor of the left now you're saying
they're leaking all in favor I'm asking
you my question answer my question based
on this evidence don't dissemble
attorney general's expired answer my
question time is expired Senator cotton
yeah so uh Merrick Garland accurately
figuring out what the story is here and
it's a story that makes absolutely no no
uh sense whatsoever
um here is Merrick Garland then
debunking the Republican talking about
point about the FBI AI being used on
parents remember this was floating
around for a while oh they're sending
the FBI they're delic they're declaring
parents to be domestic terrorists if
they go to school board meetings and the
FBI is getting involved this was during
questioning from Senator John Kennedy
didn't you understand
by the way isn't isn't John Kennedy
insufferable the chilling effect that it
would have
two parents
when you issued your directive when you
directed your criminal divisions
and your counter terrorism divisions
to um
to investigate parents
who are angry
at school boards and administrators
during covet
Senator if you just give me a moment to
put the full context I did not do that I
did not issue any memorandum directing
the investigation of parents who are
concerned about their children quite to
the contrary the memorandum that you're
talking about says at the very beginning
of the memorandum that vigorous public
debate is protected by the First
Amendment and the kind of concerns that
you're talking about are as expressed by
parents are of course completely
protected the memorandum was aimed at
violence and threats of violence against
a whole host of school Personnel it was
not aimed at parents making complaints
to their school board
and if it came in the context of a whole
series of other kinds of violent threats
uh and violence against other public
officials yeah
um they don't care they're just getting
the question on the record you have to
understand you know Merrick Garland's
doing the best he can but all of these
questions are just performances and
these are sort of like auditions for
who's going to get on Hannity later on
last night another interesting moment
Senator Marsha Blackburn told Merritt
Garland she's going to send him a bunch
of Twitter you told me earlier
favor I am going to send you a letter
with a whole lot of Twitter and
different feeds to help you and that
she's going to help him by sending him
feeds investigation for the Hope Clinic
yeah Marcia Blackburn will help the
Department of Justice by sending Merrick
Garland a whole bunch of Twitter once a
viewer sent me a whole bunch of Alta
Vista I barely knew what to do with it
it was really crazy and then lastly here
is Republican senator from Arkansas Tom
Cotton
asking Merritt Garland
why did the doj not arrest protesters
outside the homes of Supreme Court
Justices listen to how that went
consider the efforts your department has
put into tracking down everyone who is
even on the capitol Greyhounds on
January 6 2021 yeah you've dedicated
million of man-hours millions to study
videotape to do forensic analysis of
computers and devices to go knock and
conduct interviews you can't allocate
just a few agents to look at people's
social media account to say they were
president outside of a Justice home
we're going to go arrest them and charge
them it's a black letter violation of
the law our priority is violence and
threats of violence and the protection
of the lies of the justices and that's
what we're doing yeah why did you spend
all this time
trying to figure out who all of the
criminals were on January 6th and yet
you're not out there trying to figure
out who stood holding a sign outside of
a supreme court Justice's house
why isn't that evidence of bias well no
we're focused on violence and threats of
violence so that's that's why we did
things the way we did them so listen
this probably accomplished its goals in
so far as it was meant to be a
performative display of repeating the
half and dim-witted concerns of the Fox
News audience quite frankly who only has
these concerns because the very same
people on these panels told them here's
what you need to be concerned about and
so it probably accomplished that goal
Merrick Garland did absolutely fine but
every single one of these hearings just
a complete and total face plant and
they're not going to stop because
they're then going to use these hearings
to justify we did things we accomplished
things even though these hearings
accomplish nothing I don't know how many
of you have been following the
anti-semitic sort of troll group
that has been harassing Jewish folks in
Florida and in other parts of the
country but I have absolutely
fascinating video of Volusia Sheriff
Mike Chitwood
going nuclear on these Neo-Nazi lunatics
this is a very interesting video I'm
going to play for you this was from just
a few days ago The Daily Beast article
about it explains a week after a
Neo-Nazi hate group circulated through
the Daytona Beach Florida area
displaying and distributing extremist
propaganda the County's Top Cop has had
enough a seething Volusia Sheriff Mike
Chitwood held the press conference on
Monday said this isn't about Free Speech
this is about violence it is very very
much worth looking at this take a listen
You'll first hear just a few seconds
this is video from Vice news a few
seconds of these so-called protesters
just harassing Jewish people and then
we'll hear from uh Sheriff Chitwood
[Music]
we are not going to tolerate this let me
tell you this is not about Free Speech
this is about violence two days after
the incident at the speedway one of
these gdl members and remember gdl means
goyum Defense League it's it's an
anti-semitic group
bushed and shot to Jewish Orthodox folks
outside of their synagogue in L.A
there's a lot of people in this room and
there's a lot of people around this
country of the Jewish faith who are on
their hit list
they try to be smirk your character
they try to put that threats out on you
and threaten you and your family yeah
well I wear that as a badge of honor
because I too by these clown group want
to shut my big mouth and put a bullet in
the back of my head
go for it that's my message to you go
for it you came to the wrong County I
stand with my Jewish friends and I'm
honored to be on your Hit List it's an
honor to be to be short after by a bunch
of punk thugs like you that's my
personal message with that I'll turn it
over people who are common
the calmer people will now be allowed to
speak listen good good for this guy and
this of course alone isn't actually
going to shut these clowns down but the
part of the problem is
it gets some attention the these clowns
get some attention and the videos sort
of go viral but then it doesn't get the
same serious handling that some other
things do and as the sheriff points out
it's very easy to say all right they're
standing outside of a dairy mart with a
sign about Jews but it goes beyond that
and it gets to it becomes real world
violence and we see examples of it so
good for the sheriff more folks should
be aware of the fact that these troll
groups are harassing people who are or
who they believe to be Jewish and
sometimes they're just wrong sometimes
they harass people who aren't even
Jewish now that it matters but it's just
sort of like by the way
um and uh if more sheriffs and if law
enforcement dealt with it more the way
Sheriff Chitwood is uh we would probably
all be far better off so good for him we
have a YouTube channel youtube.com the
David Pacman show which I would love for
you to subscribe to it's free to do and
we also have a Spanish YouTube channel
which you can find at davidpackman.com
Spanish whichever of the two languages
you prefer to consume uh Progressive
political analysis in it is available to
you and that's a beautiful thing
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
whatever you think is eventually going
to happen in the 2024 primary Trump's
lead is exploding in multiple polls this
is the reality of the situation right
now is it early yes can things change
yes is Trump's main opponent a guy who
hasn't even declared a candidacy yet Ron
DeSantis meaning that the numbers may
not really tell us everything we need to
know absolutely but Trump's February
polling bump
simply cannot be denied you know one of
the things I will often say
is we should look at an average of polls
rather than any one poll if you're going
to look at one poll ideally it will be a
highly rated pollster not the CD or
unrated pollsters of no uh good
reputation ideally we would if we look
at one poll it would be a highly rated
pollster but in in a perfect world we
would look at a number of highly rated
polls and take a look at the average
trend lines and say what does this tell
us in general well looking at a bunch of
new polls Donald Trump is expanding his
lead but DeSantis hasn't announced
here's an axios article that summarizes
it four new polls
show Trump has received a boost in
Republican support with one survey
showing him hitting 50 support in a
crowded field
uh could it be the visit to the train
derailment site in East Palestine Ohio
Maybe
could it be his campaign stops in South
Carolina I don't know but here are the
numbers new Emerson poll has Trump
leading DeSantis by 30 55 to 25 that
used to be a 26 point lead in January
that same poll shows Trump getting a a
four-point bump uh 255.25 Trump gets 72
percent support among Republicans with a
high school degree or less
that same poll found Trump ahead of
Biden 4642 but DeSantis trailing Biden
other polls new Yahoo news you gov poll
has Trump with an eight-point lead on
DeSantis 47-39 in the last one DeSantis
was ahead so that went from a four-point
DeSantis lead wrong Des Sanctus a
DeSantis lead was four now it's Trump
plus eight that's a 12 point swing in a
short period of time you then have the
Republican polling firm Echelon insights
finds Trump ahead of DeSantis by
1546-31 last month Trump was only up by
two so that's a 13 Point gain for the
failed former president and then in the
first Fox News presidential primary poll
remember Fox News polling is actually
quite good Fox itself doesn't do the
polling upholster does it but these are
Fox News uh branded polls they find
Trump ahead of DeSantis by 15 43-28
a number of important caveats here
in general Trump does better when the
polls just say if it's Trump or DeSantis
who do you want when the polls say if
it's Trump or DeSantis or Nikki Haley or
Ted Cruz or Tim Scott or Mike Pompeo or
Mike Pence or uh Sarah Palin the more
people that are included
um the smaller Trump's lead is and
sometimes DeSantis is actually still
ahead in those polls that include
multiple candidates so this is why Trump
knows it's actually better for him for
there to be more candidates if there are
more candidates he does better in the
polling okay now is it possible that
this polling bump for Trump prevents Ron
DeSantis from announcing anything is it
possible Ron DeSantis will look at these
numbers and say wow Trump built a lead
he added four points eight points
sometimes double digits over me over the
last month is this a sign I shouldn't
even get involved it's hard to say
because privately if you're Ron DeSantis
and big Republican donors are coming to
you and saying listen I've done I've
said nothing yet if you run I will
support you and I will throw a bunch of
money behind you if you're Ron DeSantis
and you've got a bunch of wealthy
Republicans who are telling you that you
could reasonably end up thinking I'm
gonna get the money to catch up fine
Trump's leading but it's March of 2023
the primary isn't really going to be
until June July of 22 May June July
April May June July of 2024 I have
plenty of time and with a bunch of this
Republican money I could actually catch
up that's a possibility
we have to be honest that this is not
nearly as competitive as some
commentators are making it out to be
it's early in the polls can fluctuate
sure but this is a unique situation
where you have a former president
running in a primary a former president
running in a primary will have fewer
fluctuations than normal so while Ron
DeSantis certainly could grow his
support if he gets into this race my
instinct
is that that support is going to grow
more from picking off ones and twos and
threes from people who have very little
support or even seven like Nikki Haley
in a recent poll than it is from eating
away at Trump's support that's my
prediction I'm terrible at predicting
things and you should not make any
Financial bets based on what I'm telling
you but that that's my instinct right
now it cannot be denied that it is not
as close today as many in the media are
making it seem I also have expressed to
you
if DeSantis announces and it becomes a
national campaign
desantis's total lack of Charisma and
seeming commitment to quote take the
high road even though he just comes off
as low energy when he does it I don't
think are going to help him
um so I struggled to see how if it is
Trump versus DeSantis in a long
Republican primary I just don't know how
DeSantis takes it Donald Trump
increasingly seeming unwell posting
uncontrollably to truth social truth
essential multiple times per hour about
Fox news about Ron DeSantis about rhinos
about CPAC Trump seems to have nothing
to do other than to rage and melt down
day after day hour after hour look at
the last 24 hours for Trump on Truth
sensual whatever you call it Trump
starting yesterday with quote I think
that fox board member Rhino Paul Ryan
put his boss Rupert Murdoch in a great
legal and monetary Jeopardy by
convincing him to go against his news
anchors and their belief that the 2020
presidential election was rigged and
Stalin it was Stalin in so doing Murdoch
is saying that fox behaved badly when in
fact evidence has proven that the
election was Rife with election fraud
and irregularities Ryan is bad luck for
Fox he should resign or be fired too
many incompetent rhinos at Fox News this
this is freaking brilliant
we have all of the texts that show that
the fox hosts didn't really believe
Trump won this is what's so amazing
about Trump's ability to just ignore
critical realities about the world
around us Trump wants to make the case
all those Fox hosts rightly believed
that I won but Rupert Murdoch and Paul
Ryan convinced them otherwise
um the truth is the anchors were
publicly playing up this whole it was
stolen narrative or it was Stalin As
Trump wrote but privately they were
texting each other about how it was all
BS so they didn't really believe it
that's the reality but of course so far
Rhino Paul Ryan Rupert Murdoch that's
the the target of Trump's ire Trump then
moving on to talking about polling
talking in uh speaking typing in all
caps great poll numbers leading Biden
Des Sanctus and all others by a lot make
America great again okay so going after
Rhonda Santos and Biden Trump continuing
now moving on to CPAC Now understand the
context CPAC is a joke this year last
night I tried to stream day one there
were no live streams it seems like they
canceled day one like it's it's in
shambles at CPAC Trump is speaking there
on Saturday and Trump is I guess angry
that a lot of people aren't going there
or something so Trump posts I will be at
CPAC on Saturday talking about the fact
that obviously our Capital C country is
going to quote unquote hell and how to
fix it also the Democrats use of radical
left prosecutors and the weaponization
of law enforcement it is illegal has
never been used and abused like this and
has the potential to bring down our once
fair and wonderful Capital C country
these marxists cap Marxist capital T
thugs have been after me for years only
to help them win elections in just
Capital two Capital years we have become
a third world Capital failing capital N
Nation Maga so just dissembling
completely just his brain is mush Trump
continuing now addressing why many
aren't going to CPAC the only reason
certain quote candidates won't be going
to CPAC is because the crowds have no
interest in anything they have to say
they've heard it all before and don't
want to hear it again but my speech on
Saturday night is already a sold out
monster they are trying to expand the
room in space we'll have a great time at
CPAC we always do
see you there and don't forget to vote
in the important straw poll now one of
the reasons a lot of people aren't going
to CPAC is that cpac's um uh the guy who
runs CPAC match lap is Accused despite
being anti-gay is accused of sexually
assaulting uh a male staffer of Herschel
Walkers back during the campaign I I
know that the language is sort of
colorful but he's accused the word that
was used is pummeling the junk of one of
these staffers and a lot of a lot some
Republicans seem to want nothing to do
with matchlab okay couple more posts and
again this is all within a day Trump is
just uncontrollably post truth essential
quote rumors are flying high that idiot
Rhino Paul Ryan who has greatly hurt The
credibility of Rupert Murdoch with his
ridiculous stance that the 2020 election
was all peaches and cream will be fired
like a dog from the fox board Fox is
going in the wrong direction ratings are
heading down and Murdoch just through
certain very good people who were
correct under the bus he played right
into the enemy's Camp viewers and Maga
are not happy and then lastly Trump
posting Rupert Murdoch should apologize
to his viewers and readers for his
ridiculous defense of the 2020
presidential election how many forms of
cheating and rigging does he have to see
he should also apologize to those
anchors who got it right and fire the
ones who got it wrong or were afraid to
speak up of which there were many it's
time to get rid of fake news and call it
like it is
fascinating Trump now applying his fake
news moniker his fake news moniker to
Fox News itself it is going to be a wild
primary my intent is to stream CPAC
today tomorrow and Saturday assuming it
doesn't get canceled like last night
seemed to get uh we will be starting mid
to late afternoon 4 5 pm eastern-ish
today on YouTube twitch and Facebook I
hope you'll join me and remember our our
commentary and videos widely available
on Tick Tock search David Pacman show on
tick tock
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to have back on the program today will
summer who's a politics reporter for The
Daily Beast and also co-host of the
fever dreams podcast about conservative
media he's author of the book trust the
plan the rise of Q Anon and the
conspiracy that unhinged America will
great to have you back David thanks for
having me so you know we many of us have
seen the polls that came out over the
last couple years some which will make
claims like you know a fifth of
Americans or of Republicans or whoever
believe some aspect of Q Anon beliefs
and then you know you look more deeply
and sometimes it's the slightly less
crazy beliefs and so it can be sort of
hard to know like what does it really
mean when we say this portion of the
population believes this stuff and are
some of these beliefs unique to Q Anon
or are they kind of coincidental so
let's just maybe start with what is your
understanding right now of when we talk
about Q Anon conspiracies with which
conspiracies are we talking about sure
so yeah I mean I think it might be
helpful there to sort of lay down the
the fundamental belief of Q Anon and
then you know we can go from there yeah
so I would say you know it there's so
much crazy stuff involved in this but
but I think kind of the core belief is
that the world is run by a cabal of
pedophile satanists who torture children
and Satanic rituals to drink their blood
um and that this includes people in
banking in Hollywood and the Democratic
party so that's and the the second part
of that is that this moment is going to
come called the storm where Donald Trump
is gonna essentially impose a fact
fascist dictatorship on America but they
think that's a great idea right and
execute his enemies and so I would say
that's sort of the core belief of Q Anon
so when we when people are pulled on do
you think that world Elites are in
satanic uh Cults and you know abusing
children that's in the typical in the
the teens to the the low 20
um when you ask people uh do you believe
in Q Anon straight up it's usually and
and you know I like to go with the most
conservative estimates here because as
you say I mean when we make it really
broad if we say do you think powerful
people abuse children sometimes you know
the answer is you know that's not an
unreasonable thing to believe um so when
you ask people do you believe in Q Anon
really kind of flat out they typically
say three to seven percent
um and so you know I like to go with the
that kind of stricter definition but at
the same time when you say you know talk
about satanic Cults more generally
that's still a lot of people right and
that's that's pretty crazy belief so
even on on the lower end we're talking
about millions of Americans
um a lot of the the way you just laid it
out
there are lots of similar conspiracy
theories by substituting just like one
word like for example the storm sounds
surprisingly similar to the Christian
Rapture that some believe in but just
with like slightly different details and
then the premise of the satanic
pedophiles are the cabal sounds very
similar to sort of like it's Jews who
are the ones in control how how much is
this a recycling of other versions of
these tropes and how much of it is
unique
sure I mean I I think it's a blend I
think Q Anon plays on these
centuries-old tropes for example in the
book I talk about how so much of Q Anon
I mean I mentioned the blood drinking
right uh you know that is a direct play
on this idea of the Jewish blood libel
this idea of dating back to the 13th
century that Jewish people were
murdering children to get blood to make
matzo bread for uh for Passover
um and that's everybody knows it's just
wheat and water that's the beauty of it
you know why would you adulterate it
with blood well who would do that
exactly and so but you know this idea
has set off all these pogroms and all
these murders
um and so it reserves into Anon where
you know I think it's not accidental
that so many of the villains are Jewish
people in banking or the Democratic
party or Hollywood
um at the same time I think there are
some new elements such as this idea of
this kind of mysterious clue Giver cue
and this way that it it repackages so
many old conspiracy theories but in a
way that that feels fresh to people and
with with the concept of the storm gives
them something to look forward to so
it's not just you know kind of mulling
over all this sad stuff but it gives
them this kind of Twisted Utopia that
they can help bring about is there what
is your belief now as to whether there
is a person that is q
sure so I think
um it's never been conclusively proven
but I think the best argument we've seen
for who's behind q and I should say all
the people I'm going to name have denied
it yeah but that it is laid out pretty
effectively in the HBO docu-series cue
into the storm laying out that there was
sort of a random guy interested in
conspiracy theories who started it and
then it was hijacked from him by the
people who ran eight-chan uh his father
and son Duo uh Jim and Ron Watkins yeah
and you know in that series they there's
like a quasi-confession from Ron Watkins
but no one has ever come out and said
yes I'm q but I think absent any other
evidence uh that's we can pretty much
assume I I think it's fair to say that
it's those two yeah Ron Watkins ran for
was it governor of Arizona or was it a
member of Congress I don't remember it
was a much more modest goalie he only
thought he could be a member of the
House member of the house right and uh I
mean one of the uh creepiest uh auras
surrounding that guy of anyone I can
think of
um and I don't think think that the Q
thing came up during the race did it or
now I'm not sure uh not in a major way I
mean really when he declared in this
primary
um it was and you know he had been
living in Japan for a while this is a
very kind of bizarre thing he didn't
even live in the district at the time or
he had just moved there and I think he
had had this brief uh separate career
apart from Human as like an election
fraud expert after Trump lost right so I
think he thought he thought you know
maybe I've been on one America news a
couple times now I can run for the house
and I talked to all these guys in
Arizona these political operatives and
they said you know no way this guy's
gonna get slaughtered and as it turned
out he did yeah
um when we hear sometimes we'll like
send a correspondent to Trump rallies we
have this guy Luke Beasley who's been
going and and so on and he'll talk to
people and very often people won't bring
up anything about Q or Q Anon but they
will say things like uh the current
president is actually Trump who's
controlling the military or a JFK is
alive and sometimes you can tell they
don't know the difference between in JFK
Senior and Junior and they're like oh
well one of them would be a hundred and
but it's it's all they're all very
confused and you don't know where they
got this stuff are when you hear people
say that stuff
is that connected to cue beliefs in some
way yeah absolutely I mean I think the
key thing for people to understand now
that we look and we say oh you know I
don't hear about Q down that much there
aren't too many people like out and
about with cute on shirts at the end of
2020 Q told his followers to stop saying
they were part of Q Anon I think the
sense was that the brand had been
damaged and so instead to spread these Q
anon-like ideas about the cabal JFK Jr
all these different things yeah but just
don't say hey would you like to learn
about Q Anon because you know and so now
even now I have people say oh you know
there's no Q Anon there is q and there
are the anions I mean it it's these kind
of linguistic tricks they use yeah but
but I think even for people who have
never seen Q Clues this kind of stuff I
think these ideas have become
mainstreamed in the in the excuse me
mainstreamed in the Republican party and
you know a great way to see that is
going to these Trump rallies in these
events because whether it's y'all uh
Someone Like Jordan klepper on The Daily
Show you kind of just tap a little bit
and they say well I don't like the
corruption yeah I don't mean by the
corruption they say well let me tell you
about pizza gate right right no we've
seen we've seen that develop in real
time it's often under 60 seconds you go
from some benign comment to really
really wacky wacky stuff
um Marjorie Taylor green had this moment
um around the time that Republicans took
over the house and she made it clear she
wants to kind of be on the inside now
and sided with Kevin McCarthy in the
speaker battle where she very kind of
generically said I fell for some stuff
on the internet and it's happened to a
lot of us and it was interpreted that
that was a reference to some of the Q
Anon type stuff that in 2018 she seemed
to be kind of pushing and following
um what what's your sense of that change
that we're seeing in people like green
and bobert and others with relation to
their association with Q Anon stuff yeah
so in the book I get into it I mean I
think it there's varying degrees of Q
Anon devotion on one hand you have
Lauren bobert who as far as we know
simply saw it as sort of a cynical thing
to nod at and flirt with and say well q
and on they got some interesting points
but maybe it's not for me Marshall
Taylor green on the other hand I would
put in like the top one or two percent
of Q Anon commitment when you read her
old posts I mean she was she knows more
about Q Anon than I do I wrote a book
about it right I mean she was like
getting into these kind of talmudic
debates about you know the origins of
different cue drops and saying well this
is a fake one this is a real one I mean
she was deep deep in it and so now when
she comes out and says oh I guess I I
retweeted the wrong YouTube video or
what have you I mean that is just not
true when it comes to 2024
and we have Trump as a nominee and I
think that there are some in the media
that are overstating the competitiveness
of the primary if you look at the recent
polls something has to really change for
Trump to fall out of favor
um and and that could happen it could
have but but I do think that it's not
quite as competitive as some might like
it to be if we see Trump on the path
towards the 2024 nomination do you
expect to see the Q Anon Resurgence that
we saw in previous years or does it seem
like maybe Maga has to a degree move
Beyond it
I think we're going to see I think
there's a good chance that we'll see q
and on come back um in a more visible
way I mean it's kind of been bubbling
online and and it's gaining on foothold
again now that you know elon's letting
them back on Twitter and all these
things oh yeah um but but I do think I
mean Trump is he's signaling to Q Anon
constantly I mean there was one study
that said a third of his posts on Truth
social have been promoting Q Anon uh you
know I either because like he'll just he
does it now in a way that he never did
during the campaign where he would he'll
just post memes of himself wearing a
like edited to have a Q Anon button and
stuff I mean he's really out there with
it uh and you know now he's implying
that Ron DeSantis is a pedophile he's
posting these pictures of him partying
with high school students saying could
this be our you know our beloved Ron
um and and you know I I'll just say
David I mean this is the idea that this
is not going to be a competitive primary
I'm with you I mean something could
change but people just you gotta watch
Ron DeSantis talk and you think I mean
this guy's gonna go up against Trump I
don't think so that's interesting let's
talk about that a little bit you cover
these these issues as well I understand
you you haven't announced and you've got
30 40 percent in some polls that that's
pretty remarkable stuff I mean there's
nobody's going to deny that the question
is by announcing do you take any of
Trump's support or is it going to be a
consolidation of the existing non-trump
electorate and I think it's it's sort of
the latter
um and when I think about the complete
lack of Charisma that DeSantis has and
he sort of expressed the desire to go
high and not stoop to Trump's level
which is fine in some general you know
vague vague sense but practically
speaking I don't think it's going to
work the numbers in his favor if that's
the way the primary goes I think Trump
will just crush him yeah I mean you see
these and these are all anecdotal things
but you know there was recently that
clip on Fox News which we know is trying
to favor DeSantis yeah where Brian
Kilmeade is in a diner saying well you
know primaries coming up and he's the
same ads here and everyone goes Trump
Trump trump you know and so
so and you know he's gonna have to
campaign at some point I think he's kind
of awkward enough that they're going to
try to keep him from doing much retail
campaigning but there's going to be some
video where he just looks weird and I
mean and then Trump's just gonna say you
know look at meatball Ron yeah and by
the way not I couldn't care less about
this but it's wild that in the midst of
all of the anti-drag stuff
DeSantis seems to regularly wear like
high-heeled cowboy boots which I know is
a whole thing and like I it doesn't
bother me it's just interesting how they
fall into these weird things where it
seems like is that going to help you
knowing what the kind of dialogue is
right now with some of these issues
among the people who support Trump to
begin with it all seems awkward
it it does seem awkward I mean there's
also that picture of you know Biden's
hugging people and DeSantis is kind of
stomping by yeah I mean it is I think
basically what's going on is I think the
conservative intellectuals and media are
smart enough to realize that I think
DeSantis would be a more effective and
potentially more vicious Trump right I
mean if we just see the policies he's
doing or very orban-esque oh yeah you
know he has all these conservative
intellectuals and I use that term
lightly like Chris Ruffo all right he's
you know he's a he's making University
trustees and stuff to really like kind
of crack the whip on these liberal
institutions uh whereas Trump you know
he's president he'll be stewing over
Grayden Carter again you know getting in
his own way so I think they want to do
it but uh it seems there's no evidence I
think the Grassroots wants to move on no
I think that that's uh that that's
absolutely the case uh the book is trust
the plan the rise of Q Anon and the
conspiracy that unhinged America we've
been speaking with the book's author
will summer who's also a politics
reporter for The Daily Beast and
co-hosts the fever dreams podcast
a will always great speaking to you
really appreciate it David thanks for
having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
this is my favorite clip of the week
possibly of the month maybe of 2023 so
far
you're gonna just sit down for this one
okay
if I told you
that my racial background was a
sword
what would you think you'd think
something's not right you'd think oh boy
David Pacman sir the wheel is spinning
but the hamster is dead you would think
something was very wrong with me well
that is exactly the word that Newsmax
guest Vernon Jones used during a segment
on Newsmax about when Joe Biden said I'm
a white boy but I'm not dumb or
something along those lines you you have
to see this
uh Vernon Jones
oh God I think I might just play it and
not even explain it and I'll explain it
later okay here's Vernon Jones telling
us what are the three races
what are the three races this is what he
said yesterday he said I'm a what
Baptist Church I'm a white boy but I'm
not stupid Vernon I mean
let me drop back for a second first of
all Jason my good friend uh being Latino
is no race there's only three race in
monagor Conquest sword and negroid oh my
god oh dear God there are three races
folks mono gourd
caucusord and negroid okay
do you know where this comes from
um as Dave Weigel pointed out our friend
Dave Weigel this is not a random guy
this is Vernon Jones who was endorsed by
Trump in 2022. he thankfully lost his
primary
here's what Vernon Jones is talking
about there's this old
1780s race idea that there are
essentially three races those three
races are
caucasoid
and negroid or as it was
originally called Ethiopian this is from
the 1780s it comes from the gottengen
school of History it was then later
developed further and it became one of
these racist ideologies during the age
of colonialism okay so it's insane that
Vernon Jones
particularly as a black man is saying
this is the reality about race but it's
extra insane that he's mangling beyond
recognition the names of these races
a sword what on Earth I mean it
sounds like uh it sounds like when when
little boys play swords if you know what
I'm talking about it's insane let's play
it one more time absolutely my favorite
clip maybe of the year so far Vernon I
mean were there let me drop back for a
second first of all Jason my good friend
drop back to contextualize caucusword
for us uh being Latino is no race
there's only three races monogor
Conquest sword and negroid oh God
well it it you couldn't write this stuff
but liberals create this whole new class
or a new race called Latinos they're no
race right and it is it is very clear he
did say that that Hispanics are more
diverse in their thinking than
African-American not diverse in where
they from come from as a matter of fact
Spaniards have nothing to do with
Mexicans and they all speak the same
language but again well I think
God I think Spaniards have something to
do with Mexicans if you study the
history of uh of the the Spanish why do
you think that that Spanish is spoken in
most but not all Central and South
American countries now of course now in
Mexico the population is uh many you
have a lot of multi-racialism in Mexico
which is folks from Spain who then
um uh had kids with those populations
that were already in what is now Mexico
but what it has has anyone ever heard a
dumber analysis of whatever this is
gonna create this race if you and made
it unique based on you speaking uh
Hispanic or speaking I speak Hispanic
that's exactly right sorry Spanish yeah
so let's be clear about that too this is
a verbal ink plot this is just a mess
Joe band stands in front of a black
college like Morehouse and Spelman he
says that and the reason why black
businesses aren't as successful as
whites is because they don't have
lawyers and they don't have accountants
that is racist that's sure without naive
he is he is and to say he's 80 now
saying that how about when Joe wasn't 80
when Joe didn't want black people uh to
go in his neighborhood and go to school
I didn't see it Carla Harris said so
Joey has a long history of bigotry Joe
has a long distance all right anyway I
want you to email me let me know if
there was a if if you were running a 5k
or playing intramural hockey are you
gonna be on monogord or do you prefer to
be on what I believe is the winning team
the Kaka swords I know I know where I'm
going with this one folks you let me
know uh folks there is trouble Brewing I
am in a very much trouble right now
Glenn Greenwald and Brianna Joy gray are
coming for me because I don't think
Marianne Williamson is a good candidate
uh let's back up a little bit
um I tweeted yesterday that I see a lot
of Tulsi gabbard energy
moving towards Marianne Williamson there
were a bunch of people who fell for
Tulsi in 2020 and now of course that
she's like an anti-vaxx Republican CPAC
speaker you know it's completely
unhinged what's happened with Tulsi
um some of the Tulsi people have
realized all right we got to get away
from Tulsi let's go behind someone else
and so some of that energy is moving
behind Marianne Williamson now I know
that in 2020 Glenn Greenwald was at
least a casual fan of Tulsi I have no
idea on Brianna Joy gray I'm not super
familiar with her I think she's come up
once before on the show like a couple
years ago but I don't know too much
about her so we did a segment where I
told you as I always do because I'm
honest I'm not going to pretend right I
told you I'm not super impressed with
Marianne Williamson's candidacy I think
she has every right to run
anybody who wants to run should this is
America she should be able to present
her views she should run as a Democrat
or as an independent or as a republican
whatever she wants I defend it I support
it this is what America is about and I
also mentioned that personally it's not
for me her woo-woo pseudoscience
background isn't for me she has the
right ideas on a number of political
issues but that doesn't mean I would
make her president she has no experience
she has no expertise she has no
qualifications and she is no
um sort of understanding of the way
politics works so might you go to like a
Reiki practitioner and they're like hey
I'm for Medicare for all great doesn't
mean you make them president doesn't
mean you support them in a primary but
that's all I was saying and anybody is
free to do of course whatever they want
Glenn Greenwald didn't like Glenn
Greenwald responded to this on Twitter
by saying quote those quotes Marianne
Williamson quotes I read that sounded
like Deepak Chopra Glenn says those
quotes aren't remotely kooky they're
reflective of someone engaging the vast
mysteries of Life via spirituality and
Transcendence but to utterly
conventional midwits he's talking about
me to utterly conventional midwits
serving as normalcy enforcers David
packman
anything beyond New York Times op-ed
page drek seems quote crazy so Glenn
doesn't agree with me
and then Brianna Joy gray who I think is
a podcaster
um and I guess is in League with some of
these folks I'm not super familiar with
her she tweets about this in response to
Glenn Biden guy wants to vote for Biden
again this is why part of the left is
dead and it's like which are you talking
about the only part of the left that
ever wins that ever quite literally ever
wins she's saying that part of the left
is dead
the only part that ever wins anything oh
okay very interesting as far as I know
that tweet was not particularly well
received and Brianna subsequently
deleted it okay so let's again just make
sure we're all on the same page Biden
wasn't my guy in the primary
I'm just not delusional okay Marianne
Williamson has no experience relevant to
being president of the United States if
you tell me hey you know what David we
have too many like lawyers
who are presidents or business people
who are President we need people from
different backgrounds
I'm with you I want scientists as
presidents I want you know people who
have led non-profits would be great uh
for presidents uh I would like to see
people from the field of Education be
present there's all I'm with you we have
two narrow a scope for people that
eventually become president but Marianne
Williamson has no relevant experience no
relevant expertise no qualifications and
also none of the relationships that
would make you a more effective
president she's for Medicare for all
that's great
she believes climate change should be
taken seriously great but she's not
going to push Biden to the left because
she's not even going to debate Biden if
Biden runs for reelection there's not
going to be a real primary she's not
going to debate Biden if you came to me
and you said David Katie Porter oh now
we're talking okay now we're talking if
you said David Stacy Abrams not only an
extremely skilled organizer but the
policy knowledge and understands the
system I'm Stacy Abrams absolutely
uh but Marianne Williamson is not for me
so
if the sort of followers of people in
the Greenwald Universe catch wind of
this they'll probably come after me
pretty hard but uh I'm completely
comfortable with that bring it on this
is my view Marianne Williamson I support
her having a candidacy if that's what
she wants gosh darn it there's nothing
more American than that but it's just
not for me we have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 David P uh here's
the Eggman weighing in about the right
Wingers were like laughing at Joe Biden
because he went to dinner with Jill and
they ordered the same entree it's really
weird and the Eggman called in about it
hi Dave President Joseph R Biden Jr and
his wife Jill went out to dinner
together they ordered the same uh entree
and people are making fun of them for it
or they're being ripped apart basically
I just spilled my water that's what
happened just so you know for eating the
same thing and I just want to say I
think that's adorable that's called I
don't know love or some kind of some
kind of uh
I don't know something together and I
just want to ask do you think Trump even
has a meal
with his wife no
no okay so Eggman weighing in on an
important issue I uh I couldn't possibly
more strongly defend Joe and Jill
ordering the same entree now I think
they had two different appetizers so
that there's that
um personally ordering the same entree
as my girlfriend is a no and the reason
there's actually a really interesting
article uh that's called like the
economics the economics of dining out as
a couple or something like that yes the
it's a Bloomberg article about seven
years old the economics of dining as a
couple
and it explains that one of the great
things one of the great things about
dining out as a couple is you have the
ability to sample multiple dishes it's
very common that at a good restaurant
there's more than one thing that you
want and when will you be back and it's
a little bit you know I'm not going to
be ordering two entrees that's for sure
so what I like to do is always order
something different from what my
girlfriend gets so that we can share so
that we can try it and so sometimes I'll
say you know I'm thinking about I'm
thinking about getting the fish and
chips and she'll say I I'm getting the
fish and chips I was like great you get
the fish and chips I will get something
else so now we can try the fish and
chips and we can try the other thing as
far as Joe and Jill Biden doing it more
power to them absolutely more I have no
problem and right Wingers attacking them
for it is a joke we've got a great bonus
show for you today we are going to talk
about Lori Lightfoot losing her bid to
uh remain mayor of Chicago
we are going to talk about why Americans
will lose three billion dollars in food
stamp benefits starting in March and
Republicans seem to keep forgetting who
the president was in 2020. I'll tell you
what I mean on today's bonus show don't
miss the bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and you will get instant
access to the bonus show that is hated
by conspiracy theorist Alex Jones oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
yeah everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad yeah
join pacman.com coupon code 24 starts
now I'll see you then
foreign